james charles stayed in oopsie pro jared
update oopsy yay logan paul oopsie
is anyone's surprise and poppy gloria
oopsie wait that's me
good evening i'm papi gloria welcome to
pure news
last week papa gloria discussed the
drama between james charles
and tan pewdiepie definitely missed the
mark with this video about tatty and
james
think pewdiepie completely missed the
point on that video pewdiepie video had
no research
i really wish he did more research on
youtube drama
do your research i think people did do
it right
due to poor research that does not
represent the hard-working esteemed
staff here at pew news
we have decided to let go poppy gloria
from our news team and is terminated
immediately wait a minute you can't fire
me i'm poppy gloria god dammit
good evening i'm mary
han excited to jump aboard the pew news
team
let's how can my slogan be i like ham
so what did i get i mean what did poppy
gloria get wrong
from last week well people pointed out
that james didn't delete the sugar bear
hair institutory
and when he apologized he kept it up for
24 hours
well probably because there was some
sort of contract there was an
hashtag ad on the upper left corner of
his insta story
well probably because there was some
sort of contract
sugar bear hair is the biggest
competitor of halo beauty and sbh
even this tatty in her reply okay well
it's almost like
poppy gloria said that in the last video
patty's
product is for health and beauty yes the
company does do those type as well
but he specifically held up this bag of
bottle of sleep pills and that's what he
talked about so maybe you should do some
research god damn it
i love papa gloria she was like a father
to me
clearly i didn't understand every thing
about
what's going on there's a lot of nuances
there's a lot of layers
there's a lot of onions and yes i
brushed over some points
just to save time i didn't want to make
another 43 minute video
i didn't talk about how she criticized
james for over
sexualizing his content to a very young
audience how james has a way of
manipulating and getting what he wants
and tati
obviously being fed up with that my
point was that i don't think tati was
completely innocent and justified in
making the video
and a lot of the stories doesn't add up
to me as someone
from an industry perspective as well and
seeing someone's career being completely
destroyed
over what seems to me some drama that
could easily be resolved
between the two of them i feel a bit
uncomfortable with that
jesus christ it's still going so a lot
of people
in regards to james charles have been
throwing around the world sexual
predator
because allegedly james charles has been
abusing straight guys and
to tricking them into being gay or
abusing his fame and influence or
whatever
to sway people in their sexuality the
thing however that i think is pretty
important to bring up is that the person
that
tati brings up in her videos saying that
oh the waiter he was straight
in detail about things you wanted to do
to the waiter
and when i said james he's straight your
response was doesn't matter i'm a
celebrity
obviously that's disgusting to have some
sort of idea that oh i can do whatever i
want because i'm a celebrity
uh i can also see that being said as a
joke
okay i don't know it depends on the
context regardless
it turns out the waiter made a video and
he says he was bi-curious
invited me out to his hotel at that time
i was bi-curious
and when i said james he's straight
james
he's straight okay well i guess he
wasn't so he said that he didn't
previously know
who james was didn't know who james
charles was
he said that he's the one who contacted
james afterwards the next day my sister
convinced me to
direct message james charles asked to
kiss me
and i was very nervous because i had
never done anything with a guy and i was
quite
curious so i said yes we ended up making
out for
around an hour and if i'm being honest
he's the worst kisser
oh he's bad at kissing
so clearly maybe there are other
instances i haven't seen any
proof that james has sexually abused or
harassed someone in in the sense of
trying to convince him that they're gay
maybe being pushy yes i don't know but
so at least
in this context that potty brought up
that made this whole thing explode
she was wrong about the allegations the
other argument that was brought up
to justify this whole ordeal was that
james charles promote
sugar bear whatever you went to
coachella somehow had a security issue
and magically sugar bear hair is there
with a contract in hand to save the day
for you and all of your friends
no company would ever go out of their
way to have an extra
you know handful of passes that cost
thousands of dollars a piece
like just in case companies buy extra
tickets all the time
i don't know how tacti doesn't know this
big companies
always gets tickets if there's anyone
that has tickets to events there's
always companies
so it's not weird at all that they had
extra tickets to hand out
and now it turns out seeing the text of
the situation
it didn't seem like a planned thing or
anything it just seemed like
it happened but i think it's important
to note that because of all this
false allegation came forward with a lot
of people spreading around
that information as well there was this
post on twitter that got 24 000
retweets painting james charles as this
sort of predator
when clearly this was fabricated and
false
this all started because jeffree star uh
another
beauty community person who called
james a predator someone that is close
or at least
in the circle of james charles calling
him a predator
seemed to back up that evidence or that
idea that he's some sort of predator
going after people
when we know now there's no real
evidence to support that
and even deleted this tweet tati made
this video
talking about her own brand the video
has 50 million
views she probably made between 100 000
to a million
of this video alone and in sales of this
product that she heavily promoted it's
the top link in the description
and there's a card showing up to it and
she talks about it for an extensive
amount of time
this to me sets a dangerous president of
how
much supported it is to make these type
of videos
even if you don't have all the facts or
whatever
straight i don't think this was her
intention but it's pretty crazy
now here's what i think okay i have it
all figured out
all right let's follow me here james
charles is a dumbass okay
he promoted these pills as a thank you
to this brand
that helped him without thinking too
much about it he promoted them
or he ignored the fact that tati might
get upset
either way the result was the same james
under contract couldn't delete the post
right away
but just apologize to tati tati got
really upset
that's the bad part of hollywood welcome
to business
everybody says what they need to say and
uses who they need to use to get ahead
and i have
had about enough tati is fed up with
people walking
over her or at least people in the
industry doing that to get ahead
so she realizes oh i'm gonna do that
then
i'm hard enough with this james guy i'm
sick of him always getting what he wants
i'm sick of him getting away with bad
behavior
he threw me under the bus so now i'm
gonna throw him under the bus
and instead of calling or talking to
james or picking up his calls
she decides she's gonna do this video no
matter what because she's
had enough not realizing just how
massive this thing would be
in my opinion if this whole thing stayed
in the beauty community she would have
gone
completely fine but since it's got
mainstream it's clear that people saw
through
or poked holding her motives she
realized this is not at all what she
wanted
and made this video now to try
and stop it and that's how all this
drama started yes i just pray that we
can all like
be kind with each other through this and
i'm gonna take a timeout and i'm gonna
come back and i'm gonna
continue to play with makeup because it
makes me the happiest
i think this video feels more like what
the first one should have been there was
clearly a lot of anger
i actually genuinely think she didn't
want any of these consequences
she hit twice as many subscribers and i
don't think she's proudly
saying oh i'm so happy i got this
diamond plague button
it doesn't look like anyone is happier
after this whole ordeal i don't want you
guys to subscribe i don't want you to
feel
bad for me i don't want you to feel
sorry for me this is not
about me i don't hate him i
love him and
i don't think he'll get that for a
really really long time and i don't
think anyone
will now i didn't completely jump on the
f
james charles bandwagon when i did my
first video enough people were already
doing that and i didn't really see a
point in it
i'm not as inclined to throw someone on
the bus because
i know what that feels like to happen to
you and since a lot of the things that
were presented didn't make sense
i didn't do it as well and i'm really
glad i didn't because
yes i don't think james charles is
completely
less that's not my point again but
clearly a lot of these allegations have
turned out to be true
or not as intense as described you have
all these people that
immediately unfollow james after this
whole ordeal
but and people that are pretty
controversial figures as well like shane
and i know amber chamberlain and jeffrey
they're not squeaky clean youtubers
everyone just jumped off the james
charles ship
as soon as fast as they could james lost
a fifth of his audience or more uh
his tour is most likely going to be
canceled multiple brand deals like
liberty council
relationships ruined because of this and
it sounds to me like
he needed some sort of wake-up call and
i think this video will actually do him
good
but if the whole thing was worth it i
don't think so and i still stand by i
think tati should have just
reached out to james to sort it out this
is what happens when you bring
your personal issues to public i don't
think it's a good idea
next news goody good morning actually
my name is mary hay i was just about to
upload this video
but james charles uploaded his response
video called no more lies
it's 41 minute long i'll try my best to
summarize it
because i think it's necessary to bring
up basically explains the coachella
situation
in very similar way of what i thought it
was for those of you who may not be
familiar with coachella i do want to
quickly clarify the different passes
just because it kind of is important to
this whole situation vip although vip is
still very very open to
the public artist passes however are
passed that you can
not buy the only way you can get a hold
of them is through a brand getting them
from the actual festival or through
having a personal connection to
one of the artists or bands that are
playing you went to coachella
somehow had a security issue and
magically sugar bear hair is there with
a contract in hand to save the day for
you and all of your friends
that leads me to believe that this was
orchestrated beforehand but he had an
emotional conflict
because of me and promises he made to me
behind the scenes
so he had to come up with a very clever
story and didn't tell me right when he
got back but after
despite what tata said in her video this
whole situation was definitely not a big
scheme that was orchestrated beforehand
it really did happen on the spot
the sugar ray hair team texted me the
proposal right away no money was
involved
it was no time to negotiate in a panic i
signed
and that was that on that the thing is
james charles there's so much [ __ ]
money in the beauty community
i don't think he needed to orchestrate
this whole thing
just to promote a product i'm sure james
charles can get plenty of brand deals
without do going through all this effort
it just doesn't make
any sense he showed the text of him
reaching out to tati before the post
went up and tati says that
he broke it breaks her heart that he's
promoting this brand
and you can see that james is trying to
explain
how this all happened but to be honest i
understand why tati is upset
i didn't really get it to in the
beginning but if you're working
as a sole person on creating something
and your competition is this bigger
company and to have your friend
promo that company is i can see how
that's hurtful
but just like tati showed how she's
shown so much support for james
james pointed out how he's shown a lot
of support for tati's brand as well
the very important launch to me because
it is my best friend tati she's
launching something new on halo beauty
so go check it out oh which are the real
ones
can i just say i love you guys for
putting a halo question in there
[Music]
i just received my package from halo
beauty this is tati's brand new
again i understand why tati's upset and
i understand that there
probably happened more between them for
her to lash out
to make this video but i still think
that for someone who's been a mentor for
this person to
make this video is still unjustified
james also addressed the sexual assault
allegations i don't know exactly what to
call it
but he states that first of all
i'm a 19 year old virgin i talk about
boys quite a lot on my social media
networks clearly at this point it is not
acceptable anymore and he addresses the
allegations that
he's using his fame for
sexual favors or whatever he'll never
use my fame
money or power to manipulate or get any
sexual actions
from a guy that is disgusting it is not
me
he also addresses the i'm a celebrity
line i'm a celebrity thing
is really incredibly frustrating to me
because this is an inside joke that tati
has also participated in
and she twisted this to be something far
worse than what it is this is the joke
that really is where we say i'm famous
no i'm a celebrity
and it's something that we don't say in
public very often so
it was what i thought at least from
james perspective that it was just a
joke
i can see that he also addressed the
waiter thing that where tati said
that james was manipulating someone that
was straight into being gay about a
sexuality and he told me straight up
that he was bisexual oh my god you tried
to trick a straight man into thinking
he's gay
there was no straight men being
manipulated anywhere in the story like
tati
mentioned i'm skipping some points in
this video but
james also addresses the all the
allegations that were followed up
after this video one of them being sarah
larson
for example zara larsen who's a pretty
big singer
tweeted saying that i messaged her
boyfriend multiple times
knowing he was straight and this tweet
got almost half a million likes before
it was deleted
in her defense she did later on say that
it was only one message but it was way
too late because the media had already
ran with it saying that i was harassing
straight men and wouldn't leave him
alone
someone completely fabricated a whole
entire story touching another boy in a
high school
urinal and it blew up this person came
forward a few days later
saying that it was a social experiment
but it was too late people also
completely photoshopped twitter dms of
me reaching out to these people
james also addresses jeffrey who helped
reinforce a lot of these allegations
that were spread around
but i think this is where i'm ready to
just check out because i don't really
care
for another person to get involved with
more drama
i think james addressed the big
allegations that were thrown against him
and
i'm really glad that he stood up for
himself he also talked about how this
affected him mentally
the problems with cancer culture we're
becoming okay with guilty until proven
innocent
instead of the other way around i truly
hope that everyone who participated in
this whether it be fans
influencers drama channels or credible
news sources
take the time to think about your words
and the impact that they may have on
others because i assure you and i
promise you
it's a lot stronger than what you may
think and james talked about
he wants to work on himself and it
seemed genuine as well yay
first and foremost i really want to
focus more on spending time
in person with the people that i love
and care about the absolute most and i
also have a lot of work to do in terms
of getting my mental health back to
where it needs to be in a while
and all my closest friends that are not
on my payroll all right there it is all
here
too i love how you said that because
a lot of the people that criticized
james were saying oh he needs better
people around him that aren't on his
payroll
meanwhile all these [ __ ] all these
friends of him
are the ones that are completely
publicly
trying to destroy him so i like how he
said that and he finished up with bye
sister
bye sister tanzi responded saying that
she's taking a dig
digital break to hey to heal and pray
for healing on all sides
and she says that she stand by her
videos i do not twist my words into what
they are not
hear the message okay all i know so far
is that james showed proof at least
for the allegations that were thrown
against him i haven't seen any of that
from tati
this is really crazy for me as the new
news anchor mary ham to say but
it looks like poppy gloria was right all
along and
that maybe she shouldn't have been fired
after all oh well
too bad hopefully this is all i ever
have to say about this
because it's getting a bit old at this
point
regardless of any half truth or
half-lives
or whatever if there's anything i want
to see at this point i just want to see
tati
and james in a picture saying we're
trying to work this out
but we're doing it in private thank you
for
the support and respect of that we're
sorry that this
whole thing became a thing anyway i
don't know something like that because
this is annoying at this point
if this drags on i'm just going to get
pissed off
bye grumpy cat internet legend dies
let's get some f's in the chat boys some
days are grumpier than others
wrestling peace grumpy cat now to some
more
happy news logan paul is getting sued
yay logan paul is sued by flu butts for
no handlebars
you know what's now logan logan paul did
a song that was
pretty damn similar to the no handlebar
song
i'm not going to say it i'm not going to
show it because it will just get
copyrighted
but now the artist of that song is suing
logan paul
for damages logan paul's song
deliberately
emulated their trumpet rift their melody
and the lyrics are nearly identical to
four successive bars and i i'm inclined
to agree with them this song is
i thought the song was a parody the
first time i heard it not an original
song
forbes estimated logan made 150 000 per
facebook post and 80 000 per instagram
post
their point dudes got money by buckets
and we won our cut
and logan has already taken down the
video i don't know if i agree with this
to be honest so in logan paul for
damages it seems opportunistic like oh
yeah the guy has money and we want it
if you think your brand is damaged by it
then yes i understand but
and he should definitely have to delete
the video maybe issuing an
apology but i don't know it seems a bit
opportunistic
but that's just my opinion which i don't
have last and finally pro
jared we didn't discuss it last time
because i we ran out of time
project red cheated on his wife heidi
his wife said i recently learned that my
husband approached
it have been freaking holly connor
behind my back for months pro jared lost
a hundred thousand subscribers
and more in regards to this and now
pro jarrett responded heidi said that
she has proof
and that she's been blaming him and that
she's he's been making her feel bad and
blah
blah
she went really hard on even the person
that
jared was with clearly a lot of anger
and resentment in this
it also came out that jared had been
giving nudes to fans
or getting them from fans as well which
is weird in itself
but also heidi was aware of this i think
that's an important distinction but now
jared got accused of soliciting nude
photos from miners so apparently
it came out that they exchanged nude
photos with a fan
and he knew i was 16 this fan said and i
think it's also like i said important to
note that
the wife knew about this they knew about
this account they knew about
the pictures now projera decided to
make his side of the story known and
it's pretty funny how
different it is from his initial
statement saying it is my hope that we
both exit this marriage with style and
grace
also pro jared god damn it why did i
have to see those photos jared
why i'm deeply sorry to anyone who has
seen
the accusation vitro or unwanted photos
well that doesn't
undo it does it jared now jared
confirmed what i already had suspicions
about which was that they were in a
polar
polyamorous marriage an open marriage a
multi-marriage
i don't know how it works and she's the
one that asked
jared to be in this type of relationship
and she
suggests that he should engage with
other women as
she has done with other men a lot of
people aren't accepting this as an
apology
people are saying well you still
solicited nudes to underage fans
and again we don't know if that's true
or not that's all i'm gonna say
what i don't like about this whole thing
is that heidi
went very public about this whole thing
when it clearly
isn't the internet's business what
happened between you two
clearly there's been some lies there
been some
deceit but i don't think both parties
are completely innocent
i don't think jared is innocent and i
don't think heidi is innocent but heidi
is the one regardless who brought this
whole thing to the light of the internet
so keeping that in mind i think this is
another example of
why does the internet need to know about
this
are you defending someone's soliciting
nudes to my net
i'm just ah goddammit that's not what
i'm saying
it's literally the exact same story in
the span of two days
one person outing the other publicly
online
one person out of them taking the
complete
fall for it when in reality most likely
both parties
are responsible but only one of them is
held accountable
i hope this could serve as a lesson for
the internet not jumping to conclusions
without there being more than more
evidence about certain things
i think this whole cancel culture is so
toxic
it seems more about who says the right
thing at the right time
and not who is in the right or who is in
the wrong i don't think the internet
should be the court of justice
but that's just my opinion smash like
subscribe
let's see 100 mil baby bye
what